Jack Dorsey Mark Zuckerberg Susan
Wojcicki you tell me what exactly is
white supremacy
who exactly is a white supremacist and
who should be banned today
question it's a simple one what is white
supremacy it's talked about a lot but I
don't hear it clearly defined a whole
lot so you tell me what constitutes a
white supremacist and where do you draw
the line at bana below fences on social
media I really want to know first off
let me start this by saying of course I
was horrified and M horrified and
condemn any in all mass shootings Christ
Church of the synagogues mosques awful
and anyone who supports that ideology
I've been very consistent I want to make
sure that there is no misconstruing what
I'm about to say that being said before
we move on to the current loosey-goosey
definitions of white supremacy before
the bodies are even cold
they've been politicizing this blaming
it on President Donald Trump on Saturday
in the morning this assault on the
synagogue and then Saturday afternoon
our hearts are with the victims take
responsibility for your actions mr.
president one about the culprit okay
really never mind that the shooter and
we can't show it from his manifesto
viciously antitrump because he saw him
as a Pro Jew race traitor never mind
that the Christ Church shooter hated
conservatives yeah and did not as far as
I'm ever did not like Donald Ron this is
a part of a disturbing trend okay
in vilifying people particularly right
now we're talking people are talking a
lot about white supremacy without
actually defined defining who the
villain is see if you understand what
I'm talking about
you know Trump is a liar but in some
ways he's quite sincere and that he has
a hard time saying things that he
doesn't mean in the moment he doesn't
feel any importance for white
nationalism and so he's not capable of
expressing it a plain old I don't think
if you look back to the beginning of his
campaign he has never separated himself
from white supremacist I can't even
believe it you know President Donald J
racist
oh right house of course he is yet the
president failed to condemn it why
because he can't because his own words
and actions are racist too that Navarro
is muy caliente she has got some sass
and dead Johnny Mathis doesn't seem to
understand that he did condemn it and
let me ask you this again what is white
supremacy the problem here is that you
hear these people mention it and they
fail to define it because according to
the media and the activists echo-chamber
white supremacists includes everybody
from course president Donald Trump but
then there's this guy who's been accused
of it and if you don't think it's enough
there's this guy who could forget if
you're this guy yeah he's one of them
and then finally by the time you get to
this actual white supremacist my point
is the term is lost all meaning yeah by
the time you get to him it's like yeah
but you said dr. ben Carson was a white
supremacist about my and don't see
myself there's a way supremacist
the point let me make this really clear
lest I come off as a hypocrite let me
define this for you because I'm gonna
challenge you to do so
the belief that anyone is inferior or
entitled to fewer basic human rights
solely based on race is evil okay
whoever believes that whoever subscribes
that worldview is a racial supremacist
just as believing that anyone wealthier
than you is entitled to fewer human
rights as those and socialism do is evil
but none of this is exclusive to white
people and that's not what the left is
using to define a white supremacist or
even a racist let me run you through a
few examples here okay then you tell me
what white supremacist means and who we
been and I want to get to Twitter in a
second if I were to tell you that Asians
on average tend to have high IQ scores
okay with that statement make me a
racist white supremacist Asian
supremacist honestly think about answer
now if I were to tell you that black
people on average not all are faster
than most people in general in part
because they have more fast twitch
muscle fibers is that racism is that
black supremacy is it white supremacy
now what if I were to make the statement
that Eastern your
pians on average not all are physically
stronger than say Asians look at that
every nary a period English name or a
genetic side from Brian Shawn one
Canadian is that white supremacy now let
me make you a little less comfortable
here but go with me in this experiment
what if I were to say that white people
on average have higher IQ scores than
black people on average is that white
supremacy because guess what I just said
the exact same thing I repeated myself I
was redundant only I used different
contrasting methods so please go ahead
and tell me which statements are
acceptable and which are not speaking of
unacceptable please bookmark this page
if you're on youtube because apparently
subscriptions notification bell may not
be working of course the only way we can
support this content is if you join up
at letters credit calm slash mug Club or
subscribe on iTunes part of this is
what's really important today's leftist
playbook is is calling everything a
white supremacist dog whistle and this
can go from simple phrases like he
choked I'll show you that in a second to
using words like we cherish our history
here you go he is appealing to those
voters whether he's doing it
deliberately or not he's whistling at
them and they're hearing it
Romney choked like a dog he choked he
went I can't breathe kind of funny
people talk about people choking
hundreds of times over the course of my
life they say that they're not so
committed to the metaphor that they then
talk about not being able to breathe
I've never seen that happen what and in
New York okay where Eric garner was
choked to death by the police and
famously had the last words I can't
breathe I can't breathe
on Saturday President Trump said that we
must all quote cherish our history tom
Perriello is a former Democratic
congressman from Charlottesville he
heard that as a dog whistle so you
believe let me get let me get this
straight okay Young Turks buzz cut you
believe that Donald Trump is possibly
the stupidest president ever but he had
the forethought he was playing not only
for DJ song he was playing a tune B
Chester when he was talking about Donald
we was talking about Mitt Romney choking
like a dog he was secretly thinking
about Eric garner because it's turn
immobilizer neo-nazis in the Northeast
that's an episode of West Wing I'd love
to see
working right what is clearly he's
clearly trying to reach the the five
borough racist voters by he's
referencing Eric garner he choked like a
duck oh yeah genius and we can't say
cherish our history and by the way those
are isolated incidents okay but it's
gotten even more sinister we've talked
about the left wanting to control
language the left wants to use
long-standing clearly defined words like
Western civilization they want to
include that among the secret
dog-whistle list now it may or may not
be true that some white supremacists are
doing that are we supposed to lose her
right to her opinions completely founded
on principles and deductive reasoning
for fear of some white supremacists
somewhere using some of this terminology
which will ultimately to make a point
that I don't even agree with when I'm
using the term Western civilization to
make a point that a white supremacist
would never agree with his will the left
is trying to cut people like you and I
off at the past simply because we
believe Western civilization is the best
in the world and I do believe that I
think a lot of you believe that that
doesn't make anybody a white supremacist
certainly not worthy of banning or D
platforming but let's let's okay let's
follow the logic trail here let me try
to use a couple of examples again I
really want liberals watching leftist
out there to give me a definition here
white supremacists and what warrants
being banned is believing that the
United States is believing that America
is superior to Mexico white supremacy
now what if I believe that the Mexican
American business owner is superior to
the white guy working with the Mexican
cartel by the way there are white people
in Mexico have you seen the soap operas
or Jesse Ventura lately he lives there I
have no communications to the United
States other than doing my off-the-grid
show which we do from various locations
so that the drones won't find me and
kill me these man is not covered under
free trade you'll take it back you're
taking back I didn't want to be the
streets because of fluoride in your tap
of course the parasites were a trade off
I didn't see coming
I sure that more questions all right
if I say that North America is superior
to Africa is that white supremacy
now what if I say that the Kenyan
Canadian immigrant who's become a civil
engineer is superior to the white South
African pimp I be clear I I don't
believe the white race or white people
are superior but I don't believe that
any person of any race is superior by
birthright in any shape or form
due to their race and look I'll be
honest here unlike a lot of ethnic
minorities this is if people want to
talk about checking priv'lege that's
never going to happen but if you want to
talk about recognizing some things about
yourself because you're white that may
may result in a different experience
sure unlike a lot of ethnic minorities
I've never particularly seen my race is
a huge part of who I am why because
there are all different kinds of white
people we're not we're not one
monolithic clan they're Irish Italian
Russian French Scottish Eastern European
but I do identify with the ideals of the
United States and yes by proxy Western
civilization the same Western ideals
that although Zephir mentioned people
risked life and limb to try and seek the
ideas of a free speech religious freedom
freedom from government tyranny all of
which by the way they created a unique
uniquely rich American experiment here's
the issue
unlike back then we have a lot of people
now not all but some people now who want
to come to this country not to take part
in that great experiment we have some
people who come now not all ah not
seeking freedom not in the boat seeking
freedom hopping across a moat or over
staying a work visa to benefit from a
welfare state only to subsequently by
the way vote against the values and
freedoms that made this country so
desirable in the first place I think
that's just wrong just as I think by the
way it's wrong for people to steal the
place of anyone who legally waited in
the queue to take part in this great
American experiment black white brown
yellow alike it doesn't matter does that
make me a white supremacist should Jack
Dorsey ban me see took to me racism and
socialism and they're saying white
supremacy now they they sort of are
tossing all racism under this umbrella
so we can even use that but white
supremacy is though the word of the
right now when people you know you get
you get a hashtag going like trained
seals that's white supremacy racism
socialism any form of economic classism
they're evil and corrosive to the human
spirit for the same reason to me in that
they are worldviews that identify you by
what you have rather than what you do
and by proxy these ideologies robbed you
of who you are you have black skin you
have white skin you have a vagina you
have more money than me
rather than looking at someone and
saying oh you studied hard in school you
worked your way into a good college name
you created a business that now allows
you to employ 5,000 people you treat
your family well you stayed with your
wife and kids you are an honest person
you are a good man and my challenge to
you is this I don't want to get high in
my tea here but when you see these
trends circulating yeah it gets my
antenna up my challenge to you is this
if we're going to talk about banning
people okay for actually inciting
physical violence predicated on a
hateful worldview fine
I get it and if I ran a social media
platform probably wouldn't want people
converting violent Nazis on their either
understood but if we are going to start
banning and censoring people just
because you throw an umbrella term out
there it is very important for you to
define exactly what it is with
tremendous specificity now I already
have I put my money where my mouth is so
Jack Dorsey Mark Zuckerberg Susan
Wojcicki and to all those who petition
these people to ban users you tell me
what exactly is white supremacy
who exactly is a white supremacist and
who should be banned
I want specifics let me see your
comments hey Here I am drinking from my
mug in a button-down how often do you
see this never so do me a favor and
yourself click one of these videos
playing in one of these boxes here or a
subscribe hit a notification bell also
because subscriptions don't really mean
a whole lot if you really want to
support the show join my club if you
don't then there's no helping you